[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
this is what democracy looks like
yesterday representative Justin Jones
preceded in the Tennessee legislator
legislature
I'm from Missouri I get the end of words
wrong what are you gonna do
the Nashville Council voted
36-0 to make sure that Justin Jones was
still the representative
in Tennessee
um
delivering back the [__] sandwich
to the Republicans that they made and
now they have to eat it
um Justin Jones not only did he go get
sworn in on the capital steps but he
walked from the council with a crown of
protesters back
to be sworn in and there's some great
words from Justin Jones and Justin
Pearson as well as we await to see if
Justin Pearson is going to be reseeded
into the legislative body they're in
Tennessee
making Cameron Sexton the biggest Alpha
cuck in Tennessee as there's more word
that um the alpha cuck speaker Cameron
Sexton doesn't even live in the district
that he represents hmm
you mean Republicans or frauds come on
man
come on man that can't be
uh we also have news there's another
person who passed away as a result of
Republican policies in Kentucky letting
anyone have weapons of war yesterday you
know I'm gonna start um broadcasting as
a cheering about this maybe that'll
change you know they're not going to
change anything so maybe we should
change our approach maybe we should just
be cheery
about how Republican policies are
murdering people and Banks grocery
stores little children in schools
parishioners and churches maybe we
should just be [__] excited about it
maybe they would take notice
you know it really is um weird
that yesterday the Nashville Council
voted 36-0 to reseat Justin Jones
because the Tennessee
speaker of the house doesn't like him
because he's black
and he doesn't he definitely does not
like
when members of his body protest with
protesters while they're black
especially when it's against gun reform
or for gun reform I should say
thank you
all the people at the Capitol in
Tennessee were asking for
was for for the for the legislator to do
something anything red flag laws
background checks not past the bill
where anyone and everyone can carry and
buy any gun they want whenever they want
like just not do that
and they did something
the Republicans in the Tennessee house
did something
they proved beyond the shadow of the
doubt that they are inept
they are not for the people
they're not for their constituents
they're not for Tennessee they're only
for their own
addiction to their power that is it that
is it
period
I don't even know that I need to go on
anymore about the Republicans in
Tennessee they did do something they
proved to the world of exactly who they
are
last night Kelly and Conway went on Fox
News did you see this she's like oh wait
wait don't you we need to win the young
people's vote hate kellyanne
the young people the reason why you they
don't you don't have their support
is because of your bone-headed dream
because of your capitulation to the gun
lobby
because of your
untetheredness to reality
and your absolute worship of the cult
leader Republican Jesus the Cheeto dust
cueing on her
so until you
don't do those things
young people gen Z is probably not gonna
be in the mass
for your
non-policies because you really don't
have any principles left anymore besides
fascism
calling calling gen z a bunch of
blue-haired lemmings I don't think
that's really gonna get them all excited
to back your policies and by the way by
the way
if you're gonna go after the blue haired
Lemmings you better understand
that a lot of gen Z aren't blue haired
people
a lot of them are real white people who
think they're conservative they've been
indoctrinated into conservatism wait
until they get out in the world
wait just wait kellyanne those those
little white teenagers that you people
have indoctrinated that'll run around
like yeah we love Trump cause my mommy
and my daddy says my grandpappy says
shrimp is good he's good for my
whiteness wait until they go meet
non-white people
wait until they find out what I found
out what I was a young adult that
everything they were taught by the
institution of white supremacy is a
[__] lie
and Justin Jones had it right yesterday
there is a feeling of the new South I'm
highly disappointed that the Democrats
chose Chicago it is what it is I really
thought that Atlanta was a good place to
have the convention
especially on the heels
of what Tennessee did to two black men
that were duly elected in the state of
Tennessee
and the [__] sandwich that they're going
to eat that they made themselves
nothing would be a better explanation
point on that than than Atlanta
but it is what it is we're gonna cause
good trouble rather it's in Atlanta or
it's in Chicago that's right we are
gonna cause good trouble anywhere we can
in any pocket of the country because I
agree with Justin Jones
when he talked about when he came to the
floor yesterday and he talked about the
new South
this is the bed that that bigots
racist fascist white supremacists have
made for themselves
they don't understand that they're the
minority ideology even though they have
a lot of power in certain parts of the
country whether it be city councils or
state legislators
maybe even the House of Representatives
of the United States for the time being
by the slimmest of margins
we see you
gen Z sees you hell I believe a lot of
baby boomers see your dumb asses and Gen
X definitely sees you I mean Gen X that
doesn't have their head all the way up
Trump's ass
the Millennials definitely see your your
stupid [__] going on
you think you listen I'm a millennial
and I'll I'll tell you that Millennials
you know they act like we're still 18 or
some [__] we're parents
we have we we have college that we're
still paying for we pay for mortgages we
have 401ks
you stupid [__]
we own property
gen Z is the one that's going to have
more trouble than Millennials did and
Millennials not only went through 911
but we went through the great crash in
2008 the Great Recession as we were
coming of age
we were starting our adulthood in the
economy in one of the lowest points in
history
modern history that is
think about that
think about that and they think
Millennials aren't resilient they think
Millennials don't know about what issues
they care about
and kellyanne Conway has the [__]
goal
to go on Fox News and say well the
problem is the young people we don't
have their vote I wonder why dummy
I wonder what it could be
maybe it's a you problem you stupid [__]
yeah I'm gonna say it I don't get that
word out a lot but I'll get it out for
kellyanne Conway for sure
bobert Marjorie Taylor green Marcia
Blackburn it's all that's a good word to
describe those folks I'm sorry it just
is you don't like it and move the [__]
on
I wonder what it could be
kellyanne
are you saying are you saying that that
the threat of taking away women's rights
in Wisconsin
was a motivation for young people to go
you're not going to take my [__]
rights what are you crazy I'm just
starting my life
I'm just starting my life and you want
to take my [__] rights away the [__]
out of here with that [__] they went and
they voted to make sure to secure the
Supreme Court of Common Sense
not a liberal libtard ideology common
[__] sense don't take people's
[__] rights away liberalism isn't
difficult to understand
it's about freedom and choice
opportunity go look the [__] word up
so until you decide
what words mean kellyanne
understand why young people are easily
convinced that Liberty
is definitely the way that people should
go I mean it gives you Choice Freedom
opportunity you can decide what you want
you can you can be a you can be a
Christian white nationalist and everyone
will point and laugh at you or you can
be someone who has common sense you may
have faith maybe in God maybe a
different God maybe you don't have a
religion at all maybe you want to have a
family maybe you don't maybe you want to
have a career maybe you want to go to
school maybe you want to go to college
maybe you just want to go to a technical
school maybe you don't want to go to
school at all maybe you're satisfied
with living
without a degree working
these are all choices that Americans
should have
we shouldn't be pinned up
to your your [__] way that you think
and the way that you want to be
and the way that you want us to be it is
not an us problem
kellyanne it is not an us problem it is
a you problem
this thing that you're talking about
like what happened in Tennessee
we're two young black men pissed off the
white crusty ball sack of a speaker
Cameron Sexton really got in his [__]
snowflake three
and [__] cuck
so much so that they had to expel them
for being loud
again it seems like loud noises is the
fascist Kryptonite
there's a new brand of liberalism I
don't know if you know that
I don't know if you know that yet or not
I don't know if you know I'm selling it
here baby every single weekday new brand
of liberalism and it's about being loud
it's about being proud and it's about
giving the power back to the [__]
people just like Justin Jones said
I don't give a [__] if it's if you're a
female if you're you're a man you're a
woman you identify as this you identify
as I don't care how tall you are I don't
care what religion you are I don't give
a [__] where you came from I don't give
a [__] if you were from the city if
you're from the country I don't give a
[__]
and gen Z doesn't either
if you give a [__] about what other
people are aren't are gonna be and
you're you're spending your time trying
to figure out how you're gonna make
people conform to what you want it's a
you problem
that's on you [__]
36-0
Was the vote
to reseat Justin Jones
and and in in Memphis these Republicans
are threatening to hold up State funding
so that they don't receive Justin
Pearson
my guess is that's gonna backfire on
them bad really [__] bad oh my God
and how they do not see this coming I
just can't how they do not see
this coming
uh Gabe Sanchez said it they made icons
at a Justin Jones and Justin Pearson
absolute civil rights icons
just like that overnight
not only in Tennessee but around the
country around the world
and they thought they thought they did
something special
because folks the tail always Wags the
dog especially over there with the
fascist
and those crusty white ball sacks that
stood up
and question
and degraded
Justin Jones and Justin Pearson in those
expulsion
proceedings
on the floor not even in the Ethics
Committee you [__] cowards
it was all the tail wagging the dog
they had to show their constituents
I thought we're going to get rid of them
uppity boys you know what I'm talking
about Justin Jones said it on the floor
that's what it was all about
full stop Gloria Johnson agrees
she was the one that wasn't ex expelled
because she's white
as a new report comes out
that even in these subcommittees
they're only doing verbal votes and it's
only the chairman gaveled down before
the verbal vote is in in Tennessee
There's No democracy in Tennessee when
Republicans are reigning because they
don't want democracy folks
they don't want it
they want the power to tell you what to
do how to be
who to love
who to worship what to worship where to
worship
in what place
that you have in society
they don't care about Freedom or rights
you know give a [__]
they don't care about people's freedom
to live to walk around to go to a bank
and work to go to a school and learn
they don't give a [__] about that
they only care about their power and the
money that comes along with it
full stop
period
and they only prove that to us in
Tennessee this week
you know you know what's crazy
and I'm enjoying this a lot
I I
this this is what movements are made of
this
the pressure the tension the pushback
the fight is what makes movements
is what pushes countries forward
is what reshapes society's thinking this
is what does it we are at an inflection
point in history folks
Justin Jones and Justin Pearson being
reseeded if Pearson is receded is only
the beginning
that's why kellyanne Conley is worried
about gen Z and the youngins the youths
the yitz
as they'd say on my cousin Vinnie the
yeetz
they're worried about it
because they know they have awoken a
sweet sleeping giant that's right we're
woke baby we're woke
and they're [__]
you know I've talked about a documentary
that I watched on Netflix
talked about it several times on the
show it's called the Hitler a career
in this movie this documentary is on
Netflix and it was made in 1977.
think about that 1977 is when this
documentary was made and the title is a
bit you know Hitler a career like God
damn
but go watch it
go watch what Nazi Germany look like
before 1980. here's what I mean by that
see how the world and the guy who made
it is is a German historian
just see how they look through the lens
of Hitler Nazi Germany in 1977 before
Ronald Reagan
before the Neo-Nazi movement and the
domestic terrorism that we had in this
country with Timothy McVeigh
the Branch Davidians and others Ruby
Ridge
before George W bush 9 11 in the war in
Afghanistan and Iraq before Barack Obama
be current came the first black
president in history in this country and
won two terms
before we set ourselves back in 2016 and
somehow on a technicality elected Donald
Trump
and now we're still dealing with
trumpism in this country all before that
before any of that history existed
go watch that movie
the context
in which you watch that movie from the
eyeballs of 1977 is very important
the reason why is because as much as we
have fascists here and I call them Nazis
because they are
Nazi Germany in 1920s and 1930s was much
different than the fabric of our country
the fabric of our country folks
has been tested
and it'll keep being tested
but it's real it is there
is no way that Kansas would have passed
that referendum in a special election
to protect women's bondedly autonomy
no [__] way
would Wisconsin do what they did this
this last week
no way in hell would those people go to
the Tennessee Capitol
to call for something just something
and the Tennessee Republicans expelled
two black members who protested with
them
and then Jones be receded in a March in
a March in Nashville Tennessee
back to the Capitol to be sworn in on
the steps
our fabric is strong
our democracy is resilient
and we are at a point in history
that will be remembered this time will
be studied folks
Dale write books about it hell
Republicans might try to ban those books
hahaha
and it's because of you the
pro-democracy coalition
the people who want Liberty who
understand who understand what it means
to live
in a democratic constitutional republic
understand the difference between
liberalism and conservatism understand
what liberalism is
and yesterday
we watched it play out
in Grand fashion
and you should be proud of your country
yesterday Tennessee should be proud of
its state
Nashville should be proud of its City
and we should be proud of Representative
Justin Jones
there's no man that has worked harder
for the activism that he has that he has
brought to Nashville that deserves what
happened yesterday
in a 36-0 vote
Republicans [__] the bet on this one
and I know we we will hold them
accountable but I tell you what
after listening to Justin Pearson and
Justin Jones speak yesterday I know
they're going to hold them accountable
one of the one of the interviews Justin
Jones said he was
he approached
speaker Saxton
and asked him if he had learned anything
Justin learned a lot
from the last couple weeks
as he walked from the council to the
Capitol they chanted this is what
democracy looks like
Justin learned that democracy
may be tattered
it may be worn
in the state house in the caucus of the
Republican Party
but out here in the real world with the
people
democracy is strong
and it will not give up the fight
and you
shouldn't give up the fight either
whether you're in Tennessee or any other
state
we are at
a very important time in history I'm
telling you 50 100 years from now they
will talk about these moments
make the best of them
for those 50 or 100 years to come
don't let up
don't be quiet don't be complacent
no justice no peace
and we will give them no peace
until democracy
is at every corner and every nook and
every cranny of our country
that's the most important message that
we can send
and Justin Jones sent that message
yesterday
in the state of Tennessee
the city council in Nashville and those
people that march with Justin Jones sent
that message not just to our country but
to the world
and we are not we are not going to sit
back and let fascists take over our
governments we are not going to let
fascism and authoritarianism take hold
in our country
and we will use the strength of our
democracy to fight back against it
doubt me just do it
I dare you because this
this is what democracy looks like and
you know we talk about it here every
single weekday Newton Eastern 11 Central
9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
make sure that you subscribe to the
YouTube channel here the Tony Michaels
don't miss a single episode also
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google two full hours every
single whole day we're gonna play a hide
and seek this week
on YouTube
now it's really kind of
it's really kind of funny on Thursday
this is what we're gonna do on Thursday
we're all gonna go over
and we're gonna get in the chat on Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube channel that's what
we're gonna do
so I'm we're gonna say it several times
over the next few days so you guys know
we're we're playing hide and seek but
I'm giving you where we're gonna hide
we're gonna hide on Gabe Sanchez's
YouTube channel we're not being banned
nothing's going on I just want to give
Gabe's YouTube channel some support over
there and the best way to do that is to
broadcast from it so on Thursday we will
broadcast from Gabe's YouTube channel
that's where the chat will be on YouTube
so remember that as you're looking for
it so here's what you got to do
make sure you do this subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast channel right down
below make sure sometime today you go
over and you subscribe to Gabe Sanchez's
YouTube channel that's super important
because we're going to play hide and
seek over there on Thursday that's where
the chat is going to be on Thursday
don't worry moderators we're gonna get
you uh your your tools over there as
well so we have so we have some
moderation
remember on Thursday we're gonna play
hide and seek
on Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel I want
to give Gage some support over on his
YouTube channel so we're going to do
that for him I know you're excited about
it I I think we're trying to do this uh
more for more creators just play hide
and seek on their YouTube channels I
think it's what we're gonna do you guys
you guys are the best audience in the
world you follow this show anywhere we
go and I noticed it when we had our
suspension so I want you to give support
to other creators
especially the creators that help with
this show Gabe Sanchez being the first
and and he's our executive producer he's
our co-host
he's our co-host maybe I'll talk to
another Creator I got him in the Green
Room you know it's Tuesday it's Tuesday
and you know what happens on Tuesday
here I mean besides Taco Tuesday it's
Texas Paul on Tuesday Texas Paul is here
and I know Texas Paul has got some [__]
to say about what has happened in
Tennessee
so don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
how is that a block rant on Democracy
holy [__] I even impressed myself I'm
just saying brush your shoulders off
are you guys ready
[Music]
can't believe it's April 11th this is
episode
371. you [__] [__] me God damn we
just keep slam dunking and slam dunking
and slam Dunkin that's how we do it here
on the Tony Michaels podcast that's what
we do
and as always on Tuesday as promised we
have your favorite Texas ball Texas Paul
how are you this morning
I'm wonderful man I am wonderful yeah
yeah I forgot much better might be
illegal there's life's pissed as hell at
me oh what'd you do
give her Kobe oh [__] so you tried to
stay away you tried to you tried to
she's pissed off huh
oh yeah yeah I better be pissed off than
pissed on she told me to keep my
infected ass in the bedroom and this
damn my beer is [__] up this morning
take a shower or something down there
you got running water there at the house
I don't know yeah man I'm clean I didn't
know of you I didn't know of you baby
I washed my butt this week well that's
good well you got to wipe it at least
once a day or so you know at least once
a day at least at least at least that's
his fault there has been a shitload of
news since last Tuesday I mean just a
[__] waterfall news we've got a
million things we can possibly talk
about I missed at least 100 of them
yesterday
but I think that what happened in
Tennessee over the last few days is some
of the most important important news
that we can have they're freaking the
[__] out like I said even kellyanne
Conway is going on Fox news she's like
these young people are oh man we're
[__] we're completely [__] yeah
you're [__]
yeah exactly oh yeah we've been telling
you this for a long time dummies
but is there any other is there any
other news that you think is more
important than what what is being shown
in Tennessee that democracy does matter
it [__] matters man
well I tell you I've been I I've been
following what's going on with Cameron
Sexton over there in Tennessee I tell
you what these guys you never find a
freaking Republican that's not a damn
criminal he's not a thief he's not a
damn pedophile he's not some piece of
[__] pervert I mean every time something
like this happens you know you got
Cameron Sexton the Speaker of the House
there turns out he's been stealing from
the people of Tennessee isn't it I don't
did you follow that
there's a lot going on with Cameron
Sexton
um a lot number one the guy is directing
it seems his uh subcommittee chairs just
to do his bidding in committees I mean
they're they're not even they're not
even holding roll call votes and
subcommittees uh to get these bills
through if they want to kill a bill they
kill it with a gavel with the
subcommittee chairman and there's
there's they don't even end The Voice
vote
um there in Tennessee now if if people
don't know and I'll let you get to your
point about him uh the other scandals
but this Scandal where they're taking
away Tennessee's democracy away from
them the voice of the people you vote
for these [__] to go to these
subcommittees and vote and when they
vote there's these voice votes they're
gambling down on the opposite of what
the voice voice votes are saying and
then when they're approached in the
halls of the Capitol there these
[__] won't even answer a
question about The Voice vote that they
just gaveled down I'm telling you
they're robbing they're robbing
tennesseans of their voice and
tennesseans don't know it but boy I tell
you what Republicans in true [__]
style these boneheads made it very well
known when they expelled Justin Jones
and Justin Pearson and trying to expel
Gloria Johnson what's the what's the uh
the controversy that which one are you
talking about with with Sexton oh Sexton
you know he doesn't want to live in his
[__] right-wing District you know he
didn't want his kids to grow up there so
he sold his big house you know in his
district bought a little bitty house and
retirement community community there
that his wife and kids don't live in
then moved to Nashville to live in a
nice blue District
s all those economies or he wants that
economy he wants those uh uh
accommodations go to a good school yeah
well yeah well yeah because you know
they're [__] tearing apart rural
communities not just in Tennessee but
all these red States
yeah yeah closing hospitals and
everything but the problem with it Tony
is the Tennessee Constitution says
you've got to live
full-time in your district oh you have
to so you're you're so his neighbor sex
is breaking the law oh my God that's
surprising
his neighbors say he doesn't live there
his neighbors are telling everybody to
listen this guy ain't never here his
family's definitely never here and
that's part of what's written in the
Constitution your family has to live
with you in your district and you have
to live in your district and the worst
part about it well not the worst part
but another shitty part about it is
they've been screwing over you know
Nashville's a blue blue area yeah so
they thought it'd be funny to screw over
all the people in Nashville that
represent Democrats by cutting their per
diem
you know they pay these these lawmakers
you know to to get hotels and eat and
they get it they get it stipend they get
a per diem every day so they cut
everybody around Nashville which was a
Democrat down to like 79 a day but
everybody else
it's over 200 a day and I'm sure that
Sexton didn't cut his per diem did he oh
hell no he's been collecting that per
diem like he still lives out in the damn
sticks right and he lives in Nashville
something like 78
000 Tony this is felony territory
let me tell you something you know what
you know what they should do I think the
Republicans should get together and
bring a motion to the floor to expel
speaker Sexton I'm just saying seems
like seems like a hell of a more of a
high crime than just going to the well
and being loud while black just seems
like to me that that would be a you know
more reason to be expelled from from the
state house there yeah I'm just saying
you know you you really expect
Republicans
he'll [__] no hell no I don't hell no
they'll they would they would they would
never they wouldn't it doesn't matter
even if they were pissing on chairs they
wouldn't expel their members they
wouldn't expel their members they only
expel black yeah they didn't expel the
pedophile they didn't expel the they got
self-admitted pedophile they didn't
expel them well you know he's one of
them
I mean is there more to say than that
yeah I mean I mean [__] they expelled
two young black men they didn't expel
the white woman she even said hey these
they're expelling them because they're
[__] black
even the white woman who didn't get
expelled that said they're not they're
not voting them out or they're voting
them out because they're black they
didn't vote me out because I'm [__]
white because she's just as loud and
just as proud about her liberalism is is
representative Jones and Pearson
what makes her different
and I'm not blaming on her I'm actually
glad that she wasn't expelled to be
quite honest I actually think that
Gloria Johnson is a hell of a fighter
um we we played several clips of Gloria
Johnson on this show fighting in
Tennessee in committee meetings trying
to and trying to get people to answer
any [__] question she could to get a
vote that made any kind of goddamn sense
yep you know I I too am glad she didn't
get expelled but you know damn well why
she didn't I mean it's all white all
white all white I mean yeah the two
black guys they got to go for doing the
exact same damn thing but you know the
white lady will yeah we just don't got
the votes for that just don't write the
votes for that I tell you what I got to
call out one of our own though Tony Jim
Strickland the mayor of Memphis that
dude's an [__] he's an [__] do you
think do you think this pressure from
the Republicans on this funding for the
stadium is going to work
no no the the Commissioners have already
said they've got the votes they're going
to vote Justin Pearson back but Jim
Strickland's been lobbying like hell
against Justin Pearson uh not doing the
right thing because he's really scared
they're going to take his Stadium money
away they're not going to take that
money away
do you know how do you know how fast
Bill these numbers would [__] tank if
you took a new football stadium away
from the Tennessee Titans I hope they
take it [__] them I hope they take it I
I'm serious I'm serious people these
Republicans are self-destructing in
every single measure and we we the
pro-democracy Coalition should not
encourage to take the shovel out of
their hands while they're digging their
political grade [__] them [__] them I'm
I'm glad they [__] decided it was a
good idea to expel the two black men and
not the white woman I'm glad they did
they're gonna pay the [__] price and
they're going to pay the price with the
anger of people out in this country and
even in the [__] world
this is I I'm I'm telling you I'm
telling you they keep complaining about
wokism but God damn they keep waking up
a sleeping giant like they want to fight
the giant I don't understand why but
they keep doing it so let's let them
[__] do it [__] it let them let them
do this stupid [__] let them show their
fascism let them show them what they
truly are and what they truly want maybe
people will [__] decide that hey this
isn't the way we want to go this isn't
democracy this isn't the voice of the
people we want Liberty we want rights we
want freedom and you people [__]
banging up government there in Tennessee
gambling down when the votes aren't the
way that they're supposed to be you
deciding what bills we can and can't
have we're voting for these [__]
officials and you need to listen to
these [__] officials I don't give a
[__] who you are and what power you
think you have and where you [__]
live in Nashville or bum [__] wherever
you pieces of [__] Sexton I'm talking to
him mainly and Governor Bill Lee too but
let's face it and Bill Lee is more of a
uh of an ink pen for bills or for
Cameron Sexton to be quite honest and
the [__] the [__] fascist inside
the Tennessee house I'm just saying but
you know that's maybe my opinion
I agree with you 100 I agree with you
100 I mean I just you know
everybody is sick and damn tired of
that's you know the and that's why we're
winning over gen Z I mean that that's
why we are winning over gen Z what do
you got you got one one group of people
that believe in democracy that will
listen to what you have to say that will
that will pay attention to your
interests and the representatives you
send to to government and then on the
other side you've got a bunch of old
[__] that will just do whatever the
hell they want to do screw you screw
democracy screw everybody we want what
we want and screw you
you know I mean that's not a real big
seller there you know especially when
you got new people coming into that
democracy Olivia Juliana had a great
tweet out the other day really fantastic
she she did she God bless her she told
us Democrats don't [__] it up right
you've got our votes now but don't count
on it you screw us over we're not going
to be there you know and I I love her
for it I love her for it democracy makes
our government responsive is that not
what we want
well I think that's the idea of a
democratic constitutional republic to be
quite honest
um you know that that's that's that's
really the the crossroad that we're at
in this country I mean we're at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life I mean I've been saying that for a
long time but really the crossroad
history that we're at here is are we
going to decide that democracies what we
want our authoritarianism which is it
democracy authoritarianism what do you
want what do you want Gabe Sanchez what
do you think you want I know I know I
think I could guess what do you think
what do you think democracy to my own
King I figured I mean I don't know I
mean it look I mean you know maybe some
days of the week you might want to
dabble in authoritarianism but you know
I don't know no I would say democracy
obviously 100 I got you I'm not trying
to [__] around with fascists you don't
want to [__] around and find well I mean
look if they're [__] if they want to
[__] around they'll find out I'm not I
think that's what happened right I don't
want to I mean I'm not trying to
actively dabble or participate in that
I'm good with
with the Democracy or
the anti
uh fascist route you know right well
some more some more [__] around and find
out um um yesterday I think I think we
broke the news here on um on the show
Donald Trump
oh this [__] idiot Donald Trump is
challenging the Mike Pence case he's
gonna peel the executive right privilege
in the Mike Pence case boy you couldn't
you couldn't say I'm guilty more than
that could you I'm just saying I mean
you could he could come out and say I'm
guilty right well you know he he says
that every day on his [__] true
special page
was out and tells
tells he records it on the internet
technically he has sat on people's shows
and said yeah I did it he sat with
Anthony and said I did it and it was my
right to do it because I was going to
sell them documents back like Nixon
18 million dollars why can't I make 18
million dollars why can't I you know how
much 18 million dollars is worth in the
1970s how much is worth now these
documents got to be worse than at least
worth 175 million dollars people are
always like why don't Jack Smith do
something because Donald won't shut the
[__] up that's right
every day every day that downtown
Jackson is like Okay okay right just
recording crime yeah he's like a
screenshot record save that got it in
the folder of you're [__] how how many
times do you think those old boys over
at the doj have just looked at each
other
like [__] looking some more notebooks
yeah
we're gonna need some more paper oh my
God
speaking of speaking of paper it sounds
like these uh classmate documents that
are leaking on the internet were printed
and taken pictures of
um outside a skiff maybe even
um which is [__] weird
normally this is not um how it happens
where we get these massive leaks of
classified documents now to classify
documents apparently are on Ukraine's
capability as the spring is coming and
and more than likely now Russian
offensive on their cyber nation is
coming
um now it's it's very unclear and
they're trying to get to the bottom of
this but really the most concerning
thing to me Texas Paul no matter where
they came from or why they're there or
how they got there who took pictures of
these [__] things or how they printed
them off and got them out it feels like
it's a contractor more than it is an
actual um agent of the CIA or any other
agency but it feels like
feels like to me that this is
um this is being done in a in in support
of Putin and Russia and the reason why
is because this is really going to do a
log Jam on how we collect some of this
intelligence
um against Russia I'm sure there's
[__] falling off buildings and
jumping off balconies like a son of a
[__] over there today
I took this originally as a Russian
psyop and I talked about that I did and
I had a guy reach out to me that I
talked to every once in a while he used
to work at the CIA and he's like Paul
listen to what they're saying
this is a psyop all right but listen to
what they're saying and it's [__]
humiliating for Russia
all of what's being released is
I kind of half-assed think that this
might be us doing this on purpose I mean
I don't mean to be a conspiracy theorist
but yeah I mean it's like so tell tell
me kind of like run through the tick
tock of that then run through the tick
tock of that of how you how you've come
to that conclusion
well like I said I was sitting there and
I kept saying look folks this when
especially when the Arctic Brett Stevens
article came out from the New York times
and I was like no no this makes no sense
whatsoever nobody's nobody's gonna face
this kind of prison time this is worse
than anything reality winner ever did
you're talking six to ten years in
prison this does doesn't feel right to
me right this isn't just one document
like reality right right yeah and and I
started talking about that and then I
had a friend of mine reach out I can't
I'm not going to get into who that is
whatever but he's like Paul oh see if he
tells us you have to kill this type [__]
is that what you're saying yes
I don't have this permission
no I I I I'm giving you [__] and he's
telling me he said look I love what
you're saying and I and I agree with you
I think it's probably an OP but I don't
think it's their op I think it's our op
it's just because if you listen to
everything that's being released
none of this is good for Russia none of
it I mean everything from the
cooperation to how much we're sending
and and you know all of it at first
taste it sounds like oh well yeah that
might be bad for us but that that's
getting out but no really it's not it
ends all of China's cooperation with
Russia which has happened
I mean China's totally changed their
Tunes since all of this started leaking
out I mean
that's the other thing about the leak
that I want to mention and and again I
have been following this closely I I've
been getting on top of it more now that
we're talking about it but um if if it
seems like this was out there on the
internet running around the internet and
no one even really knew about it like it
was days before really anyone went whoa
whoa wait a second that this [__]
shouldn't be out on the internet and
then they finally came on top of it so
that honestly now what you're saying
that and with that evidence that only
proves your point maybe even more that
you're you may be on top of something
here that it is an option and again this
is just speculation on my part but the
whole time it's been out you've had the
FBI going oh no oh
oh my look what they leaked and the CIA
is like oh dear I wonder where that came
from oops you know you don't remind me
of the movie Big Daddy when the kid
spills the milk and he gets the
newspaper and he just covers up the
good enough right right well I mean any
intelligence that leaks
um rather it is an operation against
them or not
um is going to be information that is
going to make them move right like
you're saying so China's got to move
Russia's got to move Ukraine's Got to
make decisions here no matter what the
information is how it got leaked I mean
there's ramifications to this
information and maybe it's good maybe
it's bad for the strategy of Ukraine and
the Western World and Western democracy
um but you know I think I think actually
uh after the meeting was Gigi ping and
Putin I thought everyone thought that
that was going to be a turning point and
China was really going to go all in uh
with Putin but I actually I I believe
the opposite like I was like man if Gigi
ping actually goes and see how crazy
this [__] is and that he can't
trust him like this Putin is [__]
paranoid man you can tell just by the
videotape that they release of him he
had there was a [__] thing he was
getting an award he was given out the
other day and he expected it it was like
a Jeb Bush moment where he expected
everyone to clap no one clapped and he's
like Police Club please clap please clap
and and finally people caught on and
they were like yay yay you you did it
you did it homie like it was just it was
really it was really [__] weird to
watch it
um but but I mean I I think I think even
as generals the people that are higher
in the government the oligarchs are
terrified of the fact that their
oligarchy may be gone if Putin if Putin
[__] up here
um and I think Gigi ping saw all that
because you know as as much as I'm not a
fan of Gigi ping he he's not he's not a
[__] Lackey right he's not in some
[__] he he knows what the [__] he's
doing is what I'm saying right the guy
the guy who's in basically the king of
the CCP isn't a [__] dummy right no
no and and one basic fact here that
you'll get these people you know drama
cells the the news media sells drama and
then you got a bunch of Talking Heads
all over Twitter that sell drama and
they're like oh China we gotta oh China
this and trying to let me just drop one
little fact bomb on you that the gene
that that she knows
I mean he knows this clearly
if it gets down to it where we are
actually in an adversarial position with
China
and all trade gets cut off
we have one bad economic year
that's it one year we have one bad
economic year
they have half a million people starved
to death right
and he knows it and he knows what you're
saying is they rely on us more than we
rely on them in the long in the long run
you know in the short term it's kind of
a mutual uh you know cooperation here
but in the long term and that that's one
reason why I was in favor of the chip
act and I actually think the chip act
that the Democrats in Biden sign I
believe that's one of the best
anti-china bills that we signed and and
if you're against China like if you
truly are like ah [__] China we don't
want China then you then you should be
in support of Democrats and and the
Biden administration because that chimp
act went to the heart of it because
really they reduced what you're saying
from a year of bad economy they reduced
it from about three to five years to
that year 18 months with that act
especially once we get it instituted and
we get our infrastructure up in this and
this spending gets out in the next 10
years
um and not only that but I mean just the
just the because I you know I've
definitely talked about this before
which is like you've got different areas
of China like gen which is where a lot
of these components are manufactured
I've worked with companies where you
know we've had factories or we've worked
I mean it's it's literally eight [__]
what didn't what it made in xinjiang
really I mean Jesus Christ and it's it
it is really like uh it's kind of like
if you were to imagine like a cookie
cutter Factory kind of City where you go
and you're like oh they produce this but
they also produce this other thing
that's very similar if not the same
thing for another brand right it's where
a lot of people are like I'm just going
to White Label this product and a lot of
those chips those you know fabricating
those those motherboards or those
um
uh other electronic components
um the idea is that for years right they
invested they're like look we're gonna
be this Powerhouse and everyone is going
to come to here I mean there's also in
Taiwan as well in other areas but like
China being the main Powerhouse of it
all and everyone has relied on them to
do it especially the US like it costs
more to fabricate ships in the U.S
because we just aren't specialized in
that right now and the idea that we have
this chips act where we say hey look
we're going to create jobs we're also
going to create something that is not
going to go out of style or business
right it's not like oh coal miner job
it's like you know this [__] we got 50
years of investment this is future proof
right the idea that we're making this is
future proofed not only for the Next
Generation but the following the
following them and so the idea that we
have this in our own country you know
like if we really want to make it it's
like made in America this is the
ultimate made in America thing because
it's something that will go on for years
after its implementation because there
is no removal of electronics right it's
not like they're just going to go away
you know what I I actually remember
seeing banners all over at a few uh of
these rallies that said America First on
it I wonder if they think you would they
think you would think that they would
support it you know hey Texas ball
people in the chat are wondering what's
what the context of these leaks are they
keep asking what the context because I
kind of brought the leaks up without
without giving much context around them
um and these are these are these are
very highly sensitive documents
um and it appears that they've been
printed pulled out of facilities and
then photographs have been taken and the
photographs are what are leaking on the
internet but can you give us a little
more context of what these are and and
what it means and why it's so important
these are photographs yeah it's really
not much to it the the all they are is
it it more clearly illustrates the kind
of support that we've had we've given
Ukraine over the you know since since
the invasion began it talks a little bit
more that maybe we've been a little bit
more involved on the ground than what we
wanted to admit
um that we've done a considerable amount
of training with Ukrainian forces it it
lists the material offensive Weaponry
that we were providing Ukraine uh before
we came out and said that we were going
to offer them offensive Weaponry it's
it's a big nothing Burger is what it
really is but what it really does is it
undercuts Russia's Supremacy
in Ukraine right it really shows how it
really shows how weak they are I mean
exactly exactly there really is not much
to this I mean I would like to I'd like
to throw a big Drama Oh this terrible
thing was in there that really hurts us
but it's just not there Tony it's just
right you know I mean the the worst
narrative that could come out of this is
that Ukraine Ukraine is using up a
certain
um and it's a russian-style missile that
they still have and they're using up
their stockpiles of it but the good news
is it shows that we're sending more it's
coming baby like these are going to be
restocked
um it just the question is will it be
restocked in time where Vladimir Putin
can't take advantage of this and [__]
murder more civilians with his war
crimes I mean that's really that that
that's what's at stake here is how
quickly can we get Ukraine armed against
the in the the [__] uh the the
invasion of their cyber Nation by Putin
and um him killing their civilians
um with his weaponry
my instincts are telling me that this
was kind of you know I like to say give
them rope let them hang themselves my
instincts are telling me that this is
the Biden Administration handing uh an
entire Cask of rope over to the
Republicans to start screaming like gut
shot Hogs about all the [__] that we've
been doing and putting themselves on the
wrong side of History here
to their credit the Republicans have
been really [__] quiet about this
they have not heard of people yeah yeah
I mean the good ones they use the usual
dumb ones you know like Marjorie Taylor
green and and she loves Putin by the way
yeah she loves him I mean I mean most of
them be right you've got right Mark
Taylor Greene Lauren bobert uh
uh you've got uh Rand Paul like all the
you know
um Ron Johnson Ron Johnson Michael you
know let me go vacation July 4th over in
Russia with hot dogs and hamburgers all
of these people that want to say how you
know America is this tyrannical
government or this fascist regime or
whatever it's complete projection but
also one that you know is protecting
their own their own best interests which
is if I support Putin then I will be you
know
um
I will be protected or whatever and and
I want to say there there is something
that actually just reminds me of this
whenever someone is simping for a
dictator or simping for a billionaire
just know you're going to be the first
one to go right under the bus okay right
under the [__] you mean Matt taibi no
Matt taibi is the perfect example where
he goes on I didn't mean to segue into
that no no that's exactly where I was
going with this is is Matt taibi and
Elon Musk where you know he goes on to
talk about the Twitter files gets
absolutely owned on MSNBC won't
criticize Elon Musk you know uh and did
they delete the whole thread or whatever
so then so I haven't looked but
according to what happened is Matt Tybee
was like what the [__] happened to the
Twitter files thread it's gone now who
deleted this what happened it's because
it's on his it's on his profile right
it's right right so so and oh and also
Elon I think you know Elon being like Oh
we should look into this when you really
understand and that a lot wait wait wait
wait Elon said we should look into why
it was deleted no no no at the time when
he's like oh we should really look into
these Twitter files everyone should pay
attention we should make sure that
everyone looks into this exact thing
when really what you realize is that
Matt taibi is you know he replaces uh
sisa for CIS right the cisa
intentionally does that for CIS which is
a non-profit organization and then
claiming it was a uh it was a government
agency right to say oh it was the
government that was meddling when really
no it was a it was an internet
non-profit organization you know Texas
you know Texas Paul the most
disappointing about the whole thing is
Hassan owns Matt taivi on live on air
and Embassy why why couldn't why
couldn't the [__] committee come up
with that and just [__] own him on
the record in Congress why why are
Democrats so [__] they did Tony they
win if you go back and watch them yeah
but not the way not the way that they
tick-tocked it the the way that they
made him admit the way that they even
met him he was [__] wrong
and they just didn't do it the way he
did it and that's the way they should be
doing it like that is a pure example of
how the road map of how you hold these
[__] idiots especially these Putin's
puppets like [__] Elon Musk and Matt
kaibi accountable you cannot under
stress many Assad's Talent though I mean
well that's guy he literally wrote a
book on it like he did yeah he did it
wasn't I need to get that book and read
it he he talks about how when you're
when you're like a host on air how to
[__] pen these people in the corner
yeah I mean there are there are a
handful of people that do this so well
right you don't see it coming even
though you know it's gonna come why
would anyone [__] with him he would walk
with him and Jon Stewart's another which
if you saw the clip from C-SPAN of him
talking with the secretary of defense I
think it was he was like yeah no tell me
more about how audits work and then
[__] nailed her into a corner she
walked right into it man he's like me I
don't know anything about that but you
know he does know about right and he's
like no I look through this [__] and I
know what it is so I'm gonna let you
talk your way right into this pile of
[__] right right but mataibi and Elon
Musk is just another example going on
that show getting owned and then like
just this Eerie sense of timing it was
all a coincidence obviously is that a
day later he's like wait wait where are
the where the Twitter files wait the sub
stick I can't link my sub stick oh I
can't do this what was the text messages
that you posted was it text messages so
those are DMS those are two DM screens
okay from Elon who released that was it
Manta no no Elon Musk did oh [__] me
so basically what happened Yvonne the
CEO Twitter's taking screenshots of DMS
that he's in and he's posting them on
Twitter
that what the f are you [__] kidding
me so there's no there's the other
there's a [__] the timeline uh of events
here is is there's the other reporter uh
Michael [__] I forget his name
yeah so what happened was there was this
this little spat that happened in
private right Manta won't won't
criticize Elon Musk in public he's like
I'm done with Twitter I'm leaving I'm
going to sub stack all this stuff so
then what happens is there is a there's
another one of these people who are on
the Twitter files Michael something MD
right and he was one of the
quote-unquote journalists who reported
on the Twitter files and he was talking
about how oh he shared a link and said
oh guess what we wouldn't know this
stuff if it were not for Elon Musk
releasing the Twitter files and giving
us unfettered access right so underneath
that there's this whole thing about sub
stack and they're like oh what's going
on with sub stack and Elon Musk then
says hey you know what I'm gonna do I'm
going to take screenshots these two
screenshots and I'm going to reply to
this thread with those screenshots and
look I was like oh [__] I'm grabbing
those things and sure enough Elon Musk
deletes the response and they're gone
now so this is me just pulling up the
receipts for everyone to see hold hold
that up for one second right there what
is important about that right there you
are employed at sub stack the beef with
sub stack while many Hassan was
destroying Matt taibi there was
something else that was going on sub
stack was downloading massive amounts of
data from Twitter
and the Twitter Engineers were like
you've got to cut these [__] off I
mean they he went to they went to
England musk and said this is not your
friend here they are downloading all
your data they're making you useless is
what they're doing and so they did they
cut off substance I didn't mean to
interrupt you Gabe but that is that is
the real origins of all of this let's go
back even further because
um sub stack what wasn't it like a
um kind of a cousin company of Twitter
like some that one of the original
um maybe I'm wrong on this and it wasn't
one of the original
um developers at Twitter left Twitter to
develop substack and they integrated a
lot of sub stack into Twitter or am I
wrong or is that something different
because I know there's a newsletter I
don't know that they're they're not the
same company but they they were they
were developed to kind of coordinate
with each other in the aps because that
because the the issue here is sub stack
being a competitor right sub stack being
a platform where you can do long form
posts that everyone does like hey if you
want to come check out my stuff uh you
know you can yeah they're not they're
not just written content anymore you can
have podcasts on there right I'm
actually thinking we should open one up
to put the audio version on substance so
then so then there's this whole in what
really sparked it was on Wednesday sub
stacked announced that they were in a
blog post that they were going to roll
out this thing called notes right which
is a similar style to Twitter so you
know there is this fear because wait
wait do you mean it's like a short-term
timeline type thing like yeah basically
it's short it's short form content you
know where you can just go back and
forth and it is it's a public timeline
is what you're saying like yeah yeah I
don't know how it will I don't know how
it works if like because obviously with
some sub Stacks they're like hey you
know you can read it for free or if you
want to read it and you have to
subscribe to it right which is because
that's what Matt IB is saying in this in
these um right here because he says I
get paid right you say my subscribers
employ me because his subscribers who
the people who read his his gated
content are paying to see that gated
content and that's how he's making money
on that content right like we have our
patreons it's it's kind of the same
thing Matt Ivey has his sub stack and
he's just charging people to read it
exactly we have a patreon and we charge
people to get access to the yeah I mean
like sub stack is basically like a
digital newspaper where you're saying
hey if you want to get access to New
York Times or Washington Post or
whatever it might be you pay me a dollar
a month or eight dollars a month or
whatever it might be uh Texas Paul will
be right back he had to step out for a
sec but you look at this and that's what
that's what's going on here right so
what people need to understand is uh sub
stack looks at the market right they
look at what's going on in the industry
of social media but specifically on
something that's like a Twitter right
and they look oh we got a lot of people
coming to sub stack from Twitter right
they're saying oh people are linking out
from Twitter
two longer form content on substack
Twitter's like Hey we're gonna we're
gonna increase the the character count
on Twitter so you can add your
whatever you know files documents
whatever you can do them here right
that's where the discussion should
happen
Elon Musk [__] ass [__] super insecure
fragile ego decides oh no no no hold on
hold on no no we're gonna make it longer
on Twitter and now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna we're gonna uh identify
any link that is on Twitter from sub
stack we're gonna say oh no that's bad
yeah that's that's a bad link it's like
that it's like so what do you mean but
it won't link out because I've noticed a
lot of clouds it will it will it will
link out but what happens is when you
click that link you'll get a warning
that says oh you're leaving Twitter
you're leaving Twitter to an unsecure
link right uh and that's the issue is is
is What's Happening Here in those
screenshots is Matt's Ivy's going like
you're gonna fix this and he goes yeah
I'm gonna fix it and then he's like why
did you take my [__] down he goes I
didn't take that [__] down and he's like
well I rely on sub stack and it's a it's
a main point of driving people to
substack I get paid from sub stack and
that's where they go back and forth and
they're like wait hold on you're an
employee at sub stack he goes well not
literally an employee I get paid by
people who follow an account you [__]
[__] and then he also said that he
could have worked for sub stack or
something like that well no no in the in
the thread what I took it as is he was
one of the original people who was using
substack when when sub stack originally
launched to to you know hyped the
product I mean obviously they wanted
ambassadors who would write there and
who would subscribe
is on there too like he gets all the
links for you know on Twitter but at the
end of the day what happens here is Elon
Musk is threatened he looks at he looks
at the traffic and says there's a lot of
people
like Matt's how you be and others who
link out to substack to say if you want
the longer form of this come on over
right and Elon Musk is someone who's
thinking well [__] these people are
leaving Twitter and much like any other
website you want to keep someone you
don't want to retain them for as long as
you can so he says okay well increase
the character count we'll make we'll
make tweets even longer right if you pay
me eight dollars or eleven dollars now I
think is what it is then I'll give you
longer form I'll allow you to edit in
the first 30 minutes I'll allow you to
do longer videos I'll give you
everything you need to make your own sub
stack on Twitter
and then when he sees that right because
again he's he's a [__] ass [__] a
fragile ego super [__] weak then he
then he hears that sub stack
is releasing their own version of
Twitter to say well [__] man if people
want the longer form version here and
they're coming from Twitter then you
know I'm sure someone on the product
team was like well why don't we just
make a short yeah Twitter yeah who knows
what's gonna happen on Twitter man this
guy is running this [__] into the ground
and burning wow yeah and it's not
because of the user base or because
people don't want to use the platform
it's because he's he has no [__]
monies running out right so he's like he
sell more did he sell more of Tesla I
know he dropped the prices I haven't
looked at the financial I haven't looked
at any you're muted Texas Paul you're
muted
oh he he didn't he didn't sell any more
he's really in a pickle there because he
promised his Tesla investors that he
wouldn't sell any more Tesla stock and
now he's in a [__] cash crunch in at
Twitter whereas titter as he likes to
call it
um oh [__] what a [__] child man but
yeah no this is this is a big big
problem I actually had a conversation
with Elin musk's mom on Twitter about
this very thing I am not kidding I had
an exchange with Elon musk's mom on
Twitter because she was like she made a
comment when he was first talking about
remember when they they they were
crushing links to YouTube they were
suppressing
this is when she was like oh you should
be super grateful
for having access to this because that
was the whole thing about like people
getting paid
right who was this when was this it was
a while back and so I explained to her
I explained to her
that what Twitter was I said you don't
understand Twitter is a hub for
everybody if if you want to bring your
YouTube content you bring it to Twitter
everybody's bringing all of these other
platforms to you
and that's where you make your
advertising money I you and your son
don't understand fundamentally what
Twitter is Twitter is not designed to
compete with YouTube Twitter's not
designed to compete with Instagram it's
not designed to compete with sub stack
but they are the Hub everybody uses and
so Elon Musk like Gabe is saying is
looking at this data saying oh people
are leaving my site well yeah you dumb
[__] because they found the
information
on your site which means they'll be
right back
they're not leaving forever that's the
way Twitter worked and he was too too
stupid
because he's not actually you know
everybody including me I fell for it
everybody thought he was this [__]
genius this Brainiac you know when
Twitter was a self was was a company in
and of itself before he ever got there
Tesla was doing its own thing before
England musk ever he did not invent
[__] Tesla same thing with Twitter he
comes into Twitter he doesn't [__]
fundamentally you understand
wait you're saying Elon didn't invent
electricity I heard that somewhere on
Twitter I need a minute Alexa well the
the other thing too is a lot of people
like oh elon's trying to make it a
central Hub or whatever there's an
interview there's a video out there of
Elon Musk uh talking about
uh this is before this is well before he
he bought Twitter
and they were talking about like what
Twitter could be he's like oh well
WeChat WeChat is connected with
everything in China right it's the Hub
where you go in for financial payments
and this and this and this and
everything's connected like it's part of
the government and part of all these
services and he was like well I would
just you do what WeChat did which again
it shows you that the guy that has the
guy literally has no original ideas he
sees something that's successful and
then says we don't have that here we
should do that here and then copies that
idea and then [__] messes it up the
biggest problem that I see and I didn't
understand this till I don't know a
couple months ago is um that if you go
look up the largest user-based social
media platforms Twitter doesn't even
come in the top ten never came in the
top ten like like and he paid he paid
over paid like 30 billion dollars
imagine paying 44 billion dollars and
then committing to a joke where you say
oh we're gonna change the name from
Twitter to Twitter then get into trouble
because you covered up the W from the
landlord and then you say oh well the
landlord said we couldn't cover up the W
so we painted The W White
like that's the person the guy who who
lives in a world of memes that sounds
like it's worth 44 billion dollars
man not only that not only that you tank
you tank the main company that you're
making money with he's tanking Tesla he
can't even give those [__] away
because people like [__] that guy
Detroit's gonna make way better [__]
EVS that look a hell of a lot better and
operate a hell of a lot better who gives
a [__] about the autonomy the autonomy
doesn't even [__] work half the time
anyways so who gives a [__] I mean he he
really he really Corners himself into
this into this situation where he has to
be the genius and he always proves that
he isn't right
the last
uh delivery report just tanked Tesla I
don't know what their Stock's at today
but I bet it's around 190 or less you
know I haven't checked Tesla stock today
I'll check it here in a minute but he
tanked Tesla under 200 again because of
the deliveries and the problem wasn't
the number of cars he delivered it's
that they were all
low in cars with price cuts which means
there's no meat on the bone because
everybody said okay look Lincoln's
getting in the EV Market Cadillac's
getting in the UV Market why you know
Lexus is getting in the EV Market yeah
why would you buy a Tesla from a guy
that has no real idea how to make a
luxury vehicle
from a guy that has no idea to make how
to make a luxury vehicle why wouldn't
you wait one year and buy a Cadillac or
one year and buy Alexis right and people
aren't going to wait for the used EVS on
Cadillac the people who want luxury EVS
aren't going to wait they're gonna buy
that [__] brand new they're
going to order that some [__] before
they hit the lot I mean if if you're if
you're unaware about how Elon Musk has
been desperate to get into the car
market it only makes sense why Tesla is
only going to be a solar and Battery
operation probably within the next
decade and the re if well if he doesn't
he'll be toast but the reason why is
because the auto manufacturers won't
allow him to have dealerships in any
states now you call it Monopoly or
whatever and that's not free market but
let me tell you something the owner
manufacturers are going to leverage
whatever power they have and the power
they have is to say [__] you you're not
you're not going to get ahead of us
we're going to get ahead of you dummy
you didn't invent this technology this
isn't your [__] he is no Preston Tucker
now
no Preston Tucker so so I mean and the
other thing too is um this uh he he
really [__] the bed on on autonomy
because that was one of his big cells
for commercial right this big commercial
truck he's gonna build he he really [__]
the bet on that because Tesla the
autonomy is all garbage but the other
thing you [__] the bet on was this
[__] truck holy [__] to make to make
a truck not look like a truck was the
dumbest [__] thing he's ever done in
his life like and he he paid 44 billion
dollars for Twitter I'm sorry I mean the
truck is the dumbest [__] he's ever done
in his life that that apocalypse looking
what the [__] [__] geometric shape
trick it looks like it looks like a
Pontiac Aztec and a [__] DeLorean
[__] and had a baby it honestly does I
mean that thing couldn't that thing
could not get six inches up on a curb
remember that they needed to use like
you know like a little the little
platform heels that Rhonda Santos wears
they had to use that to get up on the
curb off-road my ass
[Laughter]
I you know I I got to tell you guys I
used to be a long time ago I used to be
a heavy equipment mechanic and you're
talking about the Tesla rig okay you
cannot go in to build a rig thinking oh
let's do this lightweight they've
everything that they could Shear weight
off of Volvo's already done it
International's already done it
dumbass just how dumb this [__] is
dumbass goes in and takes weight off the
brakes
okay
sounds safe for me
and the brakes on a big truck have to be
huge yeah meaty cast iron drums because
the amount of energy they absorbed it
turns to heat and that heat has to be
dissipated and if you try to do that
light Volvo tried that once they tried
to go with all disc brakes
[__] warped out immediately just
nightmares for for shippers you know
what I mean they immediately said I
don't want that truck I don't want that
truck same thing with the freaking
Teslas everybody was like an electric
truck great it's like a locomotive
you've got a decent enough power source
electric motors are fantastic but the
[__] has to stop at 80 000 plus pounds
it has to stop
and this stupid flyer it's almost like
there's vehicles in front of it or
something
and they didn't yeah wow and they didn't
test it they didn't test it they treated
it like [__] software and put this
truck out on the market to beta test it
right your kids when you see a Tesla
you're behind a you got a 80 000 pound
truck behind you that was not tested
well City let's go back to the pickup
truck because I think
among you is it a pickup truck though
Tony right is it but here's the thing
and here's and here's the signal that I
saw when when Tesla was done when he
couldn't get this [__] thing to
market the pickup truck and [__] Ford
F-150 comes out with a pickup truck that
looks like a four to one F-150 it runs
like an F-150 it feels like an F-150 no
one knows that that son of a [__] has
an electric motor in the damn thing
besides the person who bought it or if
you see it being charged like how the
[__] didn't he know that pickup truck
owners aren't gonna buy that [__]
weird looking thing they want a pickup
truck like Ford knew it Chevy knew it
Toyota knows it they all know it they're
like why would we make something that
doesn't look like a goddamn pickup truck
for pickup truck people who want to buy
pickup trucks it's the same thing you're
saying about Cadillac and Lexus and
anyone else who's going to make these
luxury EVS why would you want why would
you want anything that isn't being
bought on the market now like I've been
in the Tesla and really honestly it
feels a little weird because all you got
is this big [__] led it looks like a
tablet that's it a tablet with a
steering wheel is what it [__] seems
like to me is that I've been in and yeah
it does a lot of cool tricks like it
does Christmas songs and [__] like that
but who gives a [__] who wants their car
to sing them a Christmas song listen I
want the [__] to get to point A to
point B I want it to look a certain way
I want to have a certain
set of [__] features and those
features are to be a car or a pickup
truck for crying out loud Tony you mean
you don't want the blinker to make fart
noises well I mean
see and I've been talking [__] about it
the whole time yeah well how I mean like
you know how how long does it take for
that joke to like spoil out for like
okay we get it man you can fart noise on
you know
I've heard some creative horns you know
or like things that you can you know for
other sounds that you you can make your
car dude
exactly
more sounds I'm like I'd much rather
hear that stuff than I would a [__]
fart noise over and over again and you
have to also remember that the Cyber
truck is I think the the cost is gonna
be like sixty thousand dollars like
sixty seventy thousand dollars depending
on like which package you get right
which will probably be even more
assuming that there's other because you
have to remember too like the way in
which the Tesla Model works the business
model was
introduce a bunch of expensive cars to
then Finance the next side of the
production to then more and more and
more and more uh uh everyday common cars
so you scale it that way what he's
trying to do right now is say hey look
I'm gonna really jump into the pickup
truck market and I'm gonna say hey we
need to make this truck which doesn't
have the same uh
volume that a pickup truck have it
doesn't have the attachment Clips it
doesn't have all the it has oh it has a
little cover what happens when that
[__] cover breaks okay you know there
are things that are much cheaper like a
tarp that many people use right and
they've done for years who work in
construction or farming or whatever it
might be they they know exactly what
they can rely on because it's you know
built for tough right or it's like all
these things that they know exactly how
it works to jump to a completely new
thing because it's Elon Musk I mean the
fact that they're going a pure electric
car that sounds pretty woke as [__] if
you ask me and the fact that they're
saying oh I want to put money into a
truck that uh has no real commercial
viability because it's going to be this
run this like unique thing that sits on
the on this on the side of the street
somewhere where everyone's like oh look
there's that [__] who who spent sixty
thousand dollars right it's different
when you're like oh there's a bunch of
Tesla cars around
it became mainstream but to make this
[__] pickup truck mainstream is going
to be one hell of an uphill battle and I
don't even know if that car could go
uphill honestly I haven't even seen the
testing on it I've seen it go on a flat
Road it can't go six inches on a curb I
highly doubt it's going to be able to go
up an actual Hill
well the other thing too is um I've been
being fed commercials for hurts uh did
you see that Tom Brady is doing
commercials for hurts can you see if you
can pull that a couple of those
commercials I don't watch TV
I've actually I've actually been fed
this um I think on YouTube they've been
running them um and if I think Twitter's
been running them actually and they're
they're promoting EV vehicles and it's
Elon Musk and someone else I'm not sure
who it is they're they're in they're in
like recliners and they have okay like a
charging station hook to them and it's
to promote Hertz EV Vehicles the the
craziest part about it is Hertz probably
isn't gonna buy [__] Teslas to rent
and I I don't know of Elon Musk has any
idea how big the rental car market is or
not but yeah um I mean especially
because you also have to remember
especially when you have Tom Brady also
the rental car market I haven't looked
lately but you have to remember the
rental car market the used cars like I
had a car that was three years old and
just a couple years ago uh the you know
coming out of the pandemic everyone's
like oh [__] you know we need we need
used cars we need rental cars because a
lot of those places sold off their stock
to keep things afloat and pay the bills
and usually well that's that's how you
most used cars get are like right
certified used cars get into the market
exactly it was after the pan well
because of the pandemic that the the
price skyrocketed for used cars so I
want I was I had a lease at three years
and I was like all right what am I going
to do I went into my dealership that I
bought it from or at least it from and
they were like uh well you're in a bit
of a unique situation your car is now
worth more three years later than it was
worth at the time in which you leased it
right did they let you buy it at a lower
contract price yeah yeah so I could fix
it and and now I'm paying off the rest
of it at a lower price but it's one of
those things where they're like oh this
is this never happens like you don't
walk in with a car because you you know
once you're off the lot that's like 10K
off the price tag right there this car
after three years of use they're like no
it's actually worth more than what you
got it for right so this commercial here
again I'm not a Tom Brady fan [__] Tom
Brady
um and really I'm we don't get paid by
Hertz but I think I think this
commercial is is significant um when it
comes to the downfall of Tesla watch
this
our new EV rental Fleet is the absolute
built nice
speaking of goats is that Tom Brady yeah
he comes in to recharge gets software
updates you know
same time next week you got it cool
let's go
[Music]
so again knowing the used car market
this only shows that elon's trying to
get used Teslas out there into the
market right like like that's that's the
sense that I get but what's going to
happen is people are going to choose
which which cars they want because Hertz
isn't gonna [__] buy fleets and
fleets and fleets year after year after
year of cards that no one wants to
[__] rent right and cars that they
can't [__] sell right so I understand
what what they're trying to do here
they're trying to position the Tesla as
the the car of Tom Brady like I get it
and I get that Elon Musk is trying to
make sure that there's a ton of used
Teslas on the market which uh I mean
essentially he's trying to drive up the
the price of the new vehicle because I
mean assuming assuming those Teslas
don't go off a cliff or into a pool or
anything like that wow yeah they're
totally tired they're totally safe to
drive you know right well I know there's
a part of me where I'm like maybe maybe
we should trust another company right a
more established company you mean an
automobile company I mean you know I
don't know I mean like if we're really
going to be American made here right
let's let's do America First you
American first sons of [__] go ahead
text Paul
no you know at the uh a lot of people
don't realize what what what has been
going on in the EV Market you have two
major players that really haven't been
um
jumping into the uh into the EV Market
Honda and Toyota
so Elon Musk has been okay and Tesla's
been okay because they just don't have
the uh the the competition I'm pulling
up a name real quick soji I know his
first name and I want to say sojisato
was his name but the new CEO of Toyota
came out and had said look
we are all in on the EV Market we are
all in on the EV Market Volkswagen two
years ago said EVS are the future we're
going to do it and if you don't know
Volkswagen Volkswagen is massive folks
it's not just the Volkswagen bring they
own Lamborghini they own uh Bentley they
own uh Audi they own uh I mean [__] man
I mean if you look at they don't like a
dozen car companies plus heavy truck
manufacturing and and these companies
have all said we're we're in and now
Toyota realized they got behind Toya uh
Honda screwed up royally and said we're
going to see how this plays out then
they got caught behind the eight ball
they're having GM make an EV for them
for the next two years until they can
get into the market in 2005. so that
you've got cool because that's that's
what everyone has to understand is is
that the car companies just can't be
like oh we're gonna make EVS now they
have to retool their entire factories
they have to retool their entire um
their entire line and their entire
process to make these vehicles and
that's what they've been waiting on
that's why they've been boxing out Tesla
out of the dealership because a lot of
people don't know this but Tesla doesn't
have its own independent dealerships he
can't have dealerships inside States and
these auto manufacturers are the ones
who boxed him out of that and they're
reason why is because they want to own
the market but I mean well just a quick
point on that here in La we have uh when
I go to the mall it's a storefront uh
option right which is you go there and
it's a Tesla store and they've got two
cars in their little like right but it's
not a dealership no is it no you walk in
you see the car you can't test drive you
can't take it it's literally it's
literally trapped inside this mall it's
like a clothing store exactly you go and
look oh I like that thing and then they
say okay great we'll ship it to you
whenever right right so so the the other
the other thing that is um really
important here is the infrastructure
bill and the reason why is because we
really we we won't and haven't had the
infrastructure for big car manufacturers
to go all in like Texas polish saying I
mean there has to be infrastructure
after the charge of these vehicles they
can't Market a vehicle I don't I don't
know if people know this or not but the
automobile was invented right and then
and then the United States said you know
what we're gonna do we're gonna build a
shitload of roads that you can drive
these automobiles on so that car
companies can sell them to you that's
how we became an automobile country
that's how we travel that's how we
transport [__] ourselves and other stuff
but but it was us it was the people who
said we'll build the roads so that way
we we the government we the people will
build the road so that way the car
manufacturers can sell the vehicles to
drive on the roads the same way as the
reason why it's taken a while to get to
this EV
um Revolution as it is in the automobile
industry for the consumer is that we
have to provide we the people have to
provide the market for it to be sold in
I mean that's important so and also you
have to look at what happens when
something hits the market it's like you
know everybody uses the the old VCR
as an example when they came out there
were over a thousand bucks when they
died you could get one at Walmart for 12
bucks I mean same thing with electric
vehicles the profit margin is going to
be massively huge on these because one
we
a chip menu a chip factor is called a
Fab they're building Fabs all over
Arizona like crazy right now they're
building battery manufacturing
facilities all over because they've
they've figured out that this is the
future man this is the future so you're
a Cadillac they have that infrastructure
to do it
yeah well your Cadillac lyric that yeah
sure it's sixty thousand dollars today
five years from now when everybody's all
in that same Cadillac lyric is still
going to be 50 60 000 but you're also
talking about adjusting for inflation so
it's really going to be like selling it
for fifty thousand dollars right or
forty thousand dollars today you know
it's just it really is and Tesla is
[__] right totally well they've lost
their brand name I'll disagree with you
there because I think uh if Tesla the
company uh kicks Elon Musk and says [__]
you and they go all in on batteries and
solar I think Tesla can make it now they
won't be in they won't be the auto
manufacturer that he wants them to be
um but they're not an auto manufacturer
they're just not they're not there
they're they're they are a battery and a
Solar Company that's what they are
um I'm gonna move on here because I I
know we could probably talk about this
forever
um we were talking about classified
documents earlier it appears that the
gang of eight I don't know if you guys
the audience does with the gang of eight
is but the gang of eight is going to be
briefed apparently it seems like maybe
today or tomorrow on all the classified
documents that were found in Mar-A-Lago
um the documents that were found in
President Biden's residence and well
Vice President Biden at the time but now
President Biden and then vice president
Mike Pence it seems like the gang of
eight is actually going to receive
um so we we're definitely going to have
Shenanigans from Republicans once these
briefings are done my guess is is
they're even going to divulge probably
classified information or at least at
least edge up to that
um at that at that point
um Texas Paul have you have you read
anything on I know Chuck Schumer made a
statement the the today about the gang
of 18 these uh are getting these
briefings um for this classified
documents I I think it's only going to
tell the story that hey look the vice
presidents Biden who's now the president
and then Pence uh having these documents
I I guess we lost Texas ball
um he must have lost connectivity but um
um it seems like there's going to be a
stark contrast between the Mar-A-Lago
documents and what was found in the vice
president I mean you have to remember so
in the gang of a you've got people like
uh you know Mitch McConnell Chuck
Schumer Uh Kevin McCarthy Hakeem
Jeffries right so it's going to be very
interesting to see exactly how people on
each party play I mean we know how
Democrats are gonna be like look this is
pretty bad stuff in terms of trump right
uh you're gonna look at Biden and say
well you know it doesn't look like these
are anything important though we don't
know but I'm it's probably safe to
assume that they're not as bad as the
documents that were discovered at
Mar-A-Lago during a legal search and
seizure of said classified Dawkins by
the FBI uh not a raid
um
but it'll be interesting to see how
Kevin McCarthy tries to spin this I
think Mitch McConnell is going to play
it safe and he's even like yeah this is
a this is a problem we should look into
this uh because I think Mitch McConnell
is more we'll say diplomatic in this
sense
um and he's definitely straight away
from the recent activity that Kevin
McCarthy has done now I could be wrong
he could totally lean into this and say
Donald Trump was totally right to take
these documents but I would imagine that
probably Mitch McConnell is going to be
more on the center on this uh Kevin
McCarthy I think is the real wild card
Marco Rubio we know obviously he's gonna
[__] cuck to Trump
um and uh I don't know about Mike Turner
but I definitely know that Marco Rubio
is one of those people who will probably
say some stupid [__] because he's got no
no spine at all and then Kev McCarthy is
probably still riding high on his giving
Tucker Carlson the class uh the the Jan
six footage
um and thinking that oh this will this
will make up for the other things that
you know the other the other uh
uh things that he gave up during the the
speakership vote right right right so
what what is going to be held against
him here here's the gang of eight uh for
those listening on the audio version
Mike Turner uh republican from Ohio Jen
Himes Democrat of Connecticut Mark
Warner Democratic Democrat of Virginia
Marco Rubio Republican of Florida Kevin
McCarthy of course the Speaker of the
House republican from California King
Jeffries the Democratic leader of the
house uh Democrat of New York Chuck
Schumer Senator Chuck Schumer Democrat
from New York and then Mitch McConnell
of course the scammy Republican uh
senator from Kentucky he's the minority
is he back from a slip and fall
situation I I don't know I don't know I
think his turtle shell saved him um
breaking but this is this is from Brian
earlier he says breaking the gang of
eight quote unquote now has access to
the classified documents found that
Trump Biden and Pence homes transparency
is important now I'm not sure I I um I'm
sure that some of this is going to be
redacted right they're not going to let
the gang of eight just happen yeah
I'm sure I would imagine like I don't
know what uh
what the the flow of information or like
the handoff here is like did the do the
doj got it and then they gave it to uh
Jack Smith right right and then does is
it Jack Smith's team that's handing them
up I feel like that would be no
appropriate Place well I I believe I
believe it's doj and coordination with
Nara that's handing this stuff off
if Nora's touching it I would imagine
they're probably striking through a lot
well you know these guys the reason
they're on the gang of eight these guys
actually have the clearance to actually
see it right I mean they these are not
just your average [__] there's a
reason Marjorie you know Trader green is
not on this list I mean there's there's
these guys all have top top clearances
they they so I don't know how much is
going to be redacted but it is important
to remember that when Mike Pence and Joe
Biden uh were found to have documents
they both retain their clearances
Trump did not yeah yeah that's good
Trump's marriage was yanked the second
he left office well and um I mean
there's a lot of reports on that I mean
they they were even not giving him full
briefings and the one reason why is
because the guy couldn't pay attention
long enough to take a full briefing yeah
unless they put his [__] name in it a
hundred times I mean I I think they just
literally just in camps locks but Donald
Trump leader of the Free World president
of the United States greatest prison of
all time is reading this document I'm
telling it I'm no I think that's a
[__] truth yeah I know I think that's
the [__] truth I mean they each had a
sandwich his name between important
things and maybe he'll like retain that
you know he's like oh right Donald Trump
traitor you know he's like uh you know
it's just you know I would imagine
that's we know the guy doesn't read he
is terrible at retaining information and
uh and it has the attention span of a
[__] I don't know what I don't know
what has a short attention span so I
guess we'll see what comes out of this
like what what news Marco Rubio makes
again I I think you're right Gabe I
think Mitch McConnell is going to hold
this as close to the chest as he
possibly can I don't think he'll
actually uh say anything about this what
do you think you know exactly what's
going to happen out of this Kevin
McCarthy and Little Marco are going to
run out and they're gonna say oh the
stuff that Jill Biden had was so
terrible it was awful Joe Biden worst
president ever I mean you know that's
exactly what they're gonna do they're
gonna I mean they're gonna they're gonna
say it and then of course you know then
there's this whole thing of like what
will be released what can be released
you know they're gonna be like oh what
we're in the Mar-A-Lago files or
whatever they're gonna call or the The
Joe Biden garage files or whatever
report the Corvette files the Corvette
files they're going to come up with some
name for it and they're gonna say what's
in there and then of course you know
uh I don't know how much Kevin McCarthy
and Marco Rubio can legally disclose
while there's a current investigation
happening uh I mean I'm sure they have
to probably play that kind of safe but
they're gonna probably paint the picture
as uh these this is black and white and
the real problem is Joe Biden and not
the real problem is or or maybe
potentially the real problem is Mike
Pence and Joe Biden but it's not Donald
Trump or they're gonna say oh it was the
same thing it's the same thing there's
nothing really different about it you
had these documents here you had those
documents there nobody got her right
okay let's go home
and I can imagine you know Marco Rubio
saying some dumb [__] and Kevin McCarthy
uh getting caught in a uh or running
away from somebody when something gets
revealed to prove that you know he was
lying about this
um because you know
I'm sure there's going to be some leak
that happens somebody somebody Whispers
something you know I I would say that
Kevin McCarthy's gonna do a full-on
self-own he always does yeah oh yeah
almost you know guys the worst part
about this is is is what this all
highlights is how much this system
really needs to be revamped it really
does this is you're talking about how
shit's classified now it's marked now
exactly how it's controlled you know
there's a guy when you order classified
material just a Cliffs know to how this
happens you request the information
there's a guy that brings it to you your
name is on a list you sign for it he
gives it to you under certain
circumstances and then you're supposed
to give it back to the guy and then he
accounts for it that's the way it's
supposed to work and it is in no way
know-how working that way right now so
they really need to revamp this system
man they do and Republicans as usual are
not going to be good faith participants
and fixing a problem our country has
Mark Warner and the Democrats are going
to sit there and they're going to just
be quiet about it they're not going to
say what anybody had they're just going
to try try to look at ways that we need
you know we need to move forward
Republicans nope they're gonna they're
gonna take a squat and [__] all over it
man just like they always do speaking of
um Republicans taking the squat and
[__] all over the place uh Mueller
she wrote is reporting I don't know if
you heard this yesterday but Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan plans on going
to taking a field trip why why he's
going to York he's not the [__]
representative in New York but he's
going to go to New York for a hearing
I'm sure that's going to go really well
for Jim Jordan honestly again the whole
don't take the shovel out of their hands
while they're digging their political
Graves hand them a [__] backhoe I
mean I'm I'm not saying this but Alvin
Bragg you really should investigate
obstruction charges on Jim Jordan see
see what I mean they're back in the
coordination you have with your criminal
defendant Donald Trump they're uh
they're back and forth is really
something every time uh you know Jim
Jordan's like hey well there's so much
crime in New York and then they're like
actually based on recent studies and
based on you know actual police
reporting we see see that there is a
decrease in crime there is a decrease in
homicide so I don't know what the [__]
you guys are smoking
I thought you were going to say what
immediately came out when this happened
everybody went back and looked at crime
statistics and Jim Jordan's [__]
district and it's far worse than New
York it is far worse than New York but
you know why they're going there Tony
they just want to oh look at this all
the crime but they're picking on Donald
Trump you know I mean it's right little
[__] Jimmy Jordan and his [__]
Republicans are sorry
get their [__] ass [__] I mean uh
Allison here with me or she wrote points
it out April 13th Trump sits for
deposition in New York AG fraud case
again uh April 13th Dominion Fox trial
begins now that Jim Jordan's gonna go
between that because on April 25th the E
Gene Carroll case begins um ask yourself
what Allison says ask yourself why Jim
Jordan is taking a field trip to New
York on April 17th for his farcical
hearing quote unquote it's just more
obstruction it's just more [__] it's
more spin it's more [__] lies out of
the out of the [__] real America
First Nazi party I mean that's all it is
because they're not they're not winning
uh in in the realm of policy in the
realm of ideas because they have none
they suck at this they're horrible at it
um now I do want to get to because I got
there's a lot of [__] news I mean
there's more documents coming out with
Jeannie Thomas's yeah there's also a
mass shooting that happened yes there's
another there's another funeral home
which is like Jesus Christ man you can't
even like you can't go to a club I can't
do one [__] show I can't do one
[__] show without there being a
goddamn mass shooting in this country
um but I gotta I gotta get to it and
we've only got about 15 minutes left so
I want to go to our headline story that
uh was on our thumbnail today yesterday
um again just to reiterate
representative Justin Jones uh one of
the Nashville districts there in
Tennessee who was expelled
um from the house by a bunch of white
dudes because he's black and he was loud
um that's the reason why he was expelled
yesterday the Council of Nashville
actually voted 36-0 to reseat Justin
Jones it was a high Fanfare High fashion
of democracy let me show you the video
if I can find it here of them voting 36
to zero and you can you can feel the
mood of the room when they do that if I
can find the video and then I'm going to
show you the video of him not only
walking to the Capitol but being sworn
into the capital this is this is inside
um the the room there in Nashville uh
yesterday I actually I actually took a
nap and I woke up to this I'm like God
damn it I missed it I missed it lying
but it's a good thing it gets archive
you know the internet's forever so I was
able to watch it after the back but
here's here's the vote to reseat just
Justin Jones Mr Clark close the machines
take the vote
eyes 36.
[Applause]
all right so we can keep moving so that
Not only was the um the vote 36-0 but
the move that was easy 36-0 right right
um now the mood a waste of money right
oh yeah
Republicans are [__] waste of space
man just full stop they're a waste of
space look at this because the mood
didn't change outside outside
um on the march to the Capitol because
Justin Jones then uh set foot in the
street to take to the Capitol because
the council's there in Nashville just
down the street from the capitol
um and he walked to the Capitol watch
this and and listen to the cheers in the
crowd listen to the chant
tell me
about democracy
so you know it it seems like the
Republican [__] to bet on this one
because let me show you
um and let me see if I can find yeah
here's here's in front of the Capitol so
he walked to the Capitol steps and this
is what happened Texas Paul they they
have the imagery of the man that they
just expelled just days ago standing on
the capitol steps being sworn in with a
crowd of people could you I you couldn't
get one Republican even even as as much
as they smell like [__] to attract this
many flies right and here here Justin
Jones is attracting a whole crowd of
protesters that are with him with him in
this fight for democracy marching with
him from the council to the Capitol and
then to Crown around to see history
being made as he's sworn in this is this
is history folks watch this
[Applause]
and I love that kiss my ass walking that
you're about to show right well so so
the um the um you see Justin Pearson
here because Justin Pearson is also his
votes tomorrow right yeah what time is
his vote do you know so I ain't taking a
[__] nap
um uh I don't know probably around the
same time as yesterday which was
4 30 East uh their time 3 30. what time
do you take a nap man uh whenever I fall
asleep here's the uh here's here's
here's the the speech that Justin gave
after he was sworn in listen to this
today we're setting a resounding mess
mocracy will not be killed in the
comfort of Silence
today we send a clear message to speaker
Cameron Sexton at the people will not
allow his his crimes against democracy
to happen without challenge
the people of Nashville have spoken
today through their council members and
democracy
we stand for the vision of a
multi-racial democracy democracy is our
is the vision we're offering to this
body this building that has forgotten it
so we're waiting now for the minutes
from the city council meeting but I want
to thank everybody for coming out the
thousands of people from across the
state and across this nation who showed
up because this is not about one person
it's not about one position but it's
about a movement of people power to
restore the soul and heart of what this
building should represent and that is
democracy
[Music]
[Applause]
and so I want to thank you all for being
here today particularly the young people
who are the heartbeat of this movement
[Music]
it was students taking walking out of
classes and taking to this Capital that
led us into the well that day calling
for common sense gun laws and the first
thing I do when I walk into this
building as a representative is to
continue that call for common sense gun
legislation
[Applause]
[Music]
secondly we are calling on house Speaker
Cameron Sexton to resign and speak of
the house
get him [__] he is an enemy of
democracy and the people have spoken and
so we will continue to speak up and
resist and show up because this is the
the rebirth the resurrection of a
movement in Tennessee that's gonna keep
going not just today but in the days
ahead we will continue to show up and
birth a new South because right here in
Nashville we got movements before led by
young people that transformed this
nation in his our time again
four together not one step back
just Justin what does this meant to you
to have the support
all right so there's a part of a speech
and Texas yeah the sorry the vote is at
1 30 tomorrow 1 30. um and that's
central time yeah Tennessee so um so
Texas Paul
um Justin Jones talks about the new
South there now you're from Texas
um which is the South I'm from Missouri
which is we're kind of the South we're
kind of the Midwest we're like the
red-headed stepchild of both I told that
to Doug Jones the other day you kind of
laughed we're the red-headed stepchild
of the South and the Midwest like we
don't fit in either way like we're at
we're the southern midwesterners I mean
if that makes sense
um but when he says the new movement of
the South this is what Kaylee and Conway
on Fox News was terrified of right
yeah and don't feel bad being from
Missouri Tony man at least you're not
Arkansas right that's true that's true
that's true I don't love my cousins as
much as they do in Arkansas
um that's true so uh I I I've got a lot
of video to show but there's one
um because he goes back into the chamber
um and he gives a he gives a really good
speech in the chamber but there's one uh
here it is this is uh this is uh Justin
Pearson there on the steps with Justin
Jones and he takes the bullhorn and he
gives a little speech Let's listen to it
they don't and if they could kick out
representative Justin Jones
that he would never again be
but they were wrong
[Applause]
not only were they wrong they were wrong
in like a matter of hours oh yeah this
is how this is how an emptin stupid
Republican I mean they they stepped in a
huge Republicans especially as as things
come out about Cameron Sexton right if
people have been following I suggest you
go look into this guy he doesn't live in
the area that he represents turns out he
might be or it probably is pocketing
money from his own campaign there's a
lot of things here that aren't looking
so good for sexing and the problem is
Sexton probably could have gotten away
with a lot of these things but per usual
Republicans uh try to own the libs and
get a spotlight shown right back on them
to show the hypocrisy
or the illegality of whatever they're
doing right and right now Cameron
sexting is getting the uh the other end
of karma as he tried to you know deliver
the the expulsion of these two these two
powerful Young Voices that he finds to
be a threat right and he was like I'm
going to use my white power because
that's what it is he's my white power to
mute the voice he literally silenced him
on the floor as he was speaking with the
button his little [__] ass [__] moment
and even then Justin Jones called him
out and so now we're finding that not
only are these are these guys going to
be reinstated I mean the votes tomorrow
with Justin Pearson but the assumption
is he will be reinstated that not only
did these guys come back you know you
know after Easter man come talk about
coming back from the dead rising you
know and and coming back into the house
to be like look
I am
your boss now you are my [__] right
because what they did was the
Republicans put these guys on a [__]
pedestal deservingly so to be to be
activists to be these icons and now the
adults in the room are these two people
there's even an interview I think it
might have been MSNBC or CNN they asked
him you know what happened he's like I
actually was in the elevator with two of
these guys right and I was like so
what'd you learn what'd you guys learn
from this huh like I'm not mad I'm just
disappointed you know like it's that Dad
moment where you're like I'm not mad
guys I'm just really disappointed that I
have to be the adult in the situation
because you guys decided to be children
and if I can [__] face planted well
here's Kelly and Conley let's see what
Kelly and Conway learned from the last
week and a half with the vote out of
Wisconsin and really to vote out of
Chicago and now uh the [__] that's
going down to Tennessee let's see what
she learned so we can't be beaten um on
this policy wise I think we've already
won the policy arguments on the economy
on education on a number of issues I
think we've got some work to do on the
young people who think um differently on
abortion perhaps or guns or climate
change but even there the Democrats
messages are usually cynical the place
I'm really con the thing I'm really
concerned about with this Laura is that
the left becomes a turnout machine with
young people because influencers have
this domino effect lemming-like effect
of people just all them wanting to be
part of the same crowd boy let me tell
you something get on the side of young
people call them Lemmings Lemmings yeah
that'll really attract them over to your
side like look what we need to do is we
need to turn out the young vote
Republicans because those Lemmings are
going to turn out for Democrats when you
make sure those Lemmings turn out right
like what the [__] are you [__] I
mean you know the best way to get your
to court voters is to call them [__]
Lemmings idiots sheep uh just a bunch of
uh followers like these are the people
that when you're like hey I really you
know what I I know the voice of the
people and that voice of the people is
to call them idiots you know what do you
think of her Texas ball what do you I
think that they have no [__] clue how
any of this works you know Tony I sat
down and I wait wait wait you mean this
you mean anything right I mean I mean
what I'm talking about they're saying
social media influencers what we do for
a [__] living being commentators they
have no idea how this works I I did the
math on it Tony I talked about 1.2
million people a week
I do on all my platforms
[__] over here Texas ball hey
I flog your show every Everything the
point is
out of 1.2 million people
1.2 million people will tell me to [__]
off instantly if I say something really
stupid or against their these are not
Lemmings people these are these are
[__] people we are not the
Republicans Republicans will sit and and
just talking point after talking point
after talking point no matter how stupid
it is no matter how many times you prove
them wrong if I say something that is
factually incorrect I get fact checked
instantly by the people that I I get it
all the time like Tony you're wrong I'm
like all right well I might be wrong but
I'm the one with the microphone so I get
to see it so here's here's the Tennessee
um Republicans statement
um about this is about Justin Jones yeah
this is in response this was yesterday
in response to him being reinstated you
want to read this game go ahead uh yeah
I'll read it from from mine okay so
Tennessee's Constitution provides a
pathway back for expulsion should any
expelled member be reappointed we will
welcome them like everyone else they are
expected to follow the rules of the
house as well as state law our state
endured a horrific tragedy on March 27th
that will never be forgotten we continue
to mourn the six lives lost as they pray
as we pray for healing we remain focused
on solutions that ensure every child and
parent feel safe in the in every
Community across the volunteer state now
the problem here
is that they release this joint
statement okay they couldn't [__] be
bothered to lift a [__] finger or
send a tweet to be like oh my God the
death of six people the the unwarranted
death could totally have been prevented
and we stand with the students who are
coming to this to to to the to the
capital to protest and say that we
should pass safer and smarter gun
legislation no no we didn't do that then
but now that their plan backfired
and put all of these Republicans
especially Cameron Sexton uh in the
spotlight to show them as bigots racist
Hypocrites fascists you name it because
they decided to silence the voids voices
of three people two of which who are
black men from speaking out to actually
represent what the people that are
literally outside of of that chamber are
yelling and chanting right they ignore
those people and they silence the people
that actually do want to represent them
and now that they were reinstated or
reappointed right they have the audacity
to release a statement to say well we
welcome anyone who has been reinstated
from expulsion but you better know don't
get uppity again or we'll do this again
and the fact that they were completely
owned embarrassed by what they did that
they try to try to try to correct
correct it and and do a little PR by
saying look if you don't if you don't
follow the law because that's what it is
which it's not or you know what they try
to pull what was not the law uh if you
don't follow the law then you'll be
expelled and also we've we mourn these
people like it took all of this
to be shown and them to be called out
for them to finally release a statement
and for them to finally acknowledge this
this horrific tragedy that happened this
this
shooting and killing of innocent people
in a elementary school it took all of
the it took several days more than you
know almost two weeks
for this to for this to happen and for
three two people to get expelled uh from
from their seats to then be reinstated
for the Republicans maybe we should say
something finally because uh you know
and it's like
the only that's the only reason they
said something the only reason they said
something is because they got called out
and they got owned they tried to own the
libs and again [__] face planted and
got owned themselves right it backfired
that's what makes me so angry about this
Tony is you know you've got Katherine
Koontz you've got Michael Hill you've
got Cynthia Peake Evelyn decas you've
got Haley Scruggs
and William Kinney
and what did the Republicans do
they meet with Democrats did they say
look at these people
look at these people we lost
I mean you should see these these kids
man they're beautiful little kids
[__] that Tony I mean all they did was
just make a spectacle of [__]
stupidity when we should have been
talking about these victims that's who
we should have been talking about who we
lost
you know
one of them was a a substitute teacher
wasn't even supposed to be there that
day
you know
I mean just
it's I don't know Tony I don't know I
just get so [__] mad that it's always
this [__] with them you know it's
never about what's really happening real
people
it's never about real [__] people for
these guys they live in this goddamn
delusional bubble and it's always about
them
always about them never about the people
you know you've got Justin Jones Justin
Pearson you've got you know Gloria
Johnson out there saying we have to do
something about this we have to do
something about this you know then we
have the shooting in Louisville finally
somebody from their [__] Circle the
guy that ran that bank got shot and all
of a sudden you get these politicians
that are like
I knew him
he was wonderful you know [__]
finally
how many of these people have died that
you didn't give a rats ass about
you know
I just I hate these sons of [__] Tony
I [__] hate the man it's like there's
no Humanity in them you know you Rick
Scott's out there he was my banker for
years
dude what about the kids in Uvalde
you didn't shed a [__] tear for them
you know tell me about the people that
died in the Covenant School you can't
tell me one of their [__] names
but your Banker got shot and now you're
all emotional
[__] these people man I'm really I'm
just tired of it Tony I'm just tired of
Republicans and and what they're saying
is it feels different it smells
different that things are changing I'm
not the only one that's tired Tony I'm
not why everybody sees them for what
they are I think I think you're right
and I think that's why
um kellyanne Conway would go on Fox News
and and say such a thing like hey there
this is going to be a turnout machine
and it ain't because Democrats are doing
something special they're just like hey
we should listen to these [__] people
like you take you take every [__]
mass shooting including the one that
just happened while we're on the air and
probably the one that'll happen after we
get off the air every single time every
single time the entire country says it's
the [__] guns it's the [__] guns
it doesn't matter who used it it doesn't
matter how they got it it doesn't matter
exactly what rival what ammunition how
many they had what door they entered if
they jumped the fence or there were
security guards or no security guards
there's sros if it was children if it
was a bank president doesn't [__]
matter if they were Republican Democrat
or some just some dip [__] with a gun
it's the [__] guns it's the [__]
guns and we keep saying it and we keep
saying we keep saying it and that's what
brother Jones and that's what Justin
Pearson and Gloria Johnson stood in the
well and were saying it's the [__]
guns do something you [__] cowards do
something do something now you [__]
cowards and they won't do it and the
reason why they won't do it because
their own [__] power and their own
[__] money and we all know it they
know it we know it they know that we
know it and we know that they know that
we know that they know it we know it
everybody [__] knows it it's the
thing that's right out in the open we
know it and that's and that's why that
is why we have to stand with democracy
I'm telling you I know it's a long road
and it's hard but that's what liberalism
is it's a difficult [__] battle it's
a difficult battle to get to a consensus
and there is a consensus in this country
we just have to force these coward
mother the [__] to get out of the way
so that we can do what we need to do to
protect our children our bank presence
people at the [__] grocery store
parishioners at churches protect people
in America from these [__] weapons of
war we could do it we can [__] do it
I gotta I got a few pieces of Business
site because we're gonna have to ever
again but I got a few pieces in the
business I want to welcome we've had a
lot of sparklers here over over the last
few weeks more and more sparklers are
coming to the audience so I want to
welcome all the people from Howell show
that have been coming and showing up and
in the chat and been talking to everyone
so welcome to all the sparklers uh our
moderator MJ has a birthday today so
when you're leaving today make sure to
make sure to tell MJ happy [__]
birthday and say it that way say happy
[__] birthday MJ so make sure to tell
her happy birthday also make sure you
subscribe to the YouTube channel here uh
the Tony Michaels podcast you don't want
to miss a single freaking episode not a
single one download every single episode
on Apple's Spotify and Google also
follow us on Facebook if you still have
a Facebook account at the Tony Michaels
and if you have an Amazon Prime account
make sure you use that Amazon Prime
account and Link it to your Twitch
account you get one free subscription
over on Twitch doesn't cost you a single
nickel but if you link it to your Twitch
account it gives us a few bucks here on
the Tony Michaels podcast also go over
to realtexaspaul.com that's
realtexaspall.com don't forget to watch
Texas Paul over there follow them on all
the social media just go to
realtexaspaul.com you'll find all all
the links there also check out Gabe
Sanchez's patreon page go to what was
that show.com that's what was that
show.com or you go to patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez are you you can do this if
you download a patreon app you just
search Gabe Sanchez it'll pull it up
yeah just search images yeah or dirty
sanchez I think that pulls it up too
yeah yeah I mean that's that's what
that's what people call me on in the
community dirty scene but um also while
you're on patreon check out my page over
there our patreons have been growing we
want to thank the audience that's how we
get paid here uh to do this show free as
we provide extra content it's extra it's
additional content over on patreon I
also want to tell you one more thing
before you leave
we're gonna play hide and seek this week
on Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel on
Thursday so keep that in mind on
Thursday we're playing hide and seek
here on the Tony Michaels podcast and
we're gonna go broadcast on Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube so what you want to do
is go down in the links below there's a
link tree down in the links below that
takes you and you can follow Gabe
Sanchez on YouTube or just type in Gabe
Sanchez on YouTube you'll find his
channel make sure to subscribe because
on Thursday again on Thursday we're
going to play hide and seek we'll be
broadcasting and the chat will be over
there on his channel thank you very much
for joining us Texas Paul is always it's
been a pleasure my friend Tuesdays is
always the best day here on the Tony
Michaels podcast because it's Taco
Tuesday and it's Texas Paul Tuesday same
time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass speaking